In industries where
there aren't people that
look like you,
go where you don't belong
because one day you will.
When we started our business,
we definitely were faced
with extra challenges,
some biases.
We had a lot of pushback
as to whether or not
Black women actually
even drink wine
or if Black woman
could run a wine business.
Of course, all of that
sort of fueled
our passion and our mission
and really working to service
this consumer that we
felt we know so well
and deserved to be represented.
Well, I think we have to
start with our sister story.
Yes.
Both of us were born in
Los Angeles
to the same father.
We grew up thinking
that we were only children
on completely different
sides of the world
and different hemispheres.
I grew up in Central Coast
of California in Monterey.
She grew up in New Zealand.
And even though we were
a world apart,
we both grew up in really beautiful
agricultural areas.
We both longed to be
winemakers
and we both actually
longed to have a sibling.
We reunited in 1999.
When I got the letter
and found out
that I had a little sister
and I was like,
this really sounds very scammy.
But I of course called the number
that was on the letter
and we actually made plans
to meet the next day.
It changed my life forever.
I just can't imagine
life without her now.
Ohhh, awww.
17 years later,
we have a
multinational wine company
and we have a non-for-profit,
the McBride Sisters
SHE CAN Fund.
We have three brands,
the McBride Sisters
Collection Wines,
which are our wines from
where I grew up
in the Central Coast of California.
And in New Zealand where Andréa grew up,
we have Black Girl Magic wines
which are premium wines
from California.
and we have SHE CAN wines,
which of course is our
wines in a can.
SHE CAN wines,
we launched in 2019.
We wanted to
take that opportunity
to give back.
We've seen a lot of the struggles
that women were having
in the industry.
So we started our professional
development fund.
Which would be scholarships,
mentorships, grants for professional women
in wine and spirits.
2020 was a little bit
of a different year.
The pandemic was starting
to take a hold of the world.
We started to see some really
disturbing numbers
around the federal funding,
the PPP grants that
were going to businesses.
And we started to learn
that Black-owned businesses,
one, were shuttering
at a much faster rate
than any other
and that 96% of the businesses
either didn't qualify
or were rejected for
the PPP funding.
And we decided that year
that we were going
to award cash grants
to Black women owned businesses.
And then we had
some amazing support
from corporate donors as well
that also were able to provide
professional services
to these businesses,
assistance with financial planning, HR,
and employee management
that some of these
businesses might need
in such a challenging time.
This wine label is called Papatūānuku
which in Māori translates to Mother Earth.
Pinot Noir is a very fickle,
hard grape to grow.
It has thinner skin
and really expresses the dirt
in which it's grown.
The wine industry has had
some version of wine education,
but it's been pretty dull.
This is my favorite wine.
We tried to create something
that would engage folks
in a new way and help them
remember what
they were learning.
Super silky soft tannins.
It just like coats
your whole mouth.
It has a really long finish
and there's really good
integration of flavor.
Traditionally, wine and
food pairings have been from
this quite Eurocentric standpoint,
duck confit and Chardonnay.
And we integrated pop culture.
We integrated contemporary ways in which
people like to eat and drink.
We're talking about
what goes with tacos.
wine and watch.
What are you watching on Netflix
and what should you pair it with.
Innovation really comes
and growth really comes
from diversity of thought.
So if you have people from all
different walks of life
and backgrounds,
it doesn't matter
what the problem is,
everybody's going to approach it
and try and solve it
in a different way.
And that's when the breakthroughs happen.
And so I think because
the wine industry
hasn't been that diverse,
there is so much opportunity.
And so we're
actually really optimistic
and excited about the future.
I think success for me will be
when this industry
fully represents
the world around us.
Yes.
That it's not
dominated by one gender
or one race of people,
that it really
is representing the consumer.
More people love wine
than ever before.
So, when I can visually see that
when we go out
in the world and that's
who's at our
industry conferences and
who's at the
winemakers conferences,
I'll feel that that's success.